Although the task of determining how many
people attend something as large as say, a
political rally or a protest may seem like
a daunting, almost impossible undertaking
to do with any accuracy, with some basic information,
it’s actually not that difficult to get
reasonably accurate results.
The most well-known method of estimating the
size of a given crowd is simply called “The
Jacobs’ Method” as an ode to its inventor,
Herbert Jacobs.
Jacobs spent a few decades working for the
Milwaukee Journal before retiring into teaching
journalism at the University of California,
Berkeley in the 1960s.
He thought up his very simple crowd size estimate
method after observing numerous Vietnam War
protests outside of his office window.
Jacobs noticed that the area the students
stood on had a repeating grid-like pattern,
meaning he could very easily count how many
students occupied a certain amount of space
by counting how many students on average seemed
to be able to stand inside a section of the
grid.
By doing this, he soon noticed some patterns.
For example, Jacobs found that in the most
densely packed crowds, each person took up
approximately 2.5 square feet.
We should note that this is the absolute upper
limit of a how dense a crowd can safely get,
as in, you simply couldn’t fit more people
into a crowd this dense without someone being
trampled or worse, which is probably why most,
including some scholarly articles on the subject
we read, simply refer to it as “mosh-pit
density”.
In a dense, but more manageable crowd, Jacobs
observed that participants had a comparably
more roomy 4.5 square feet whilst those in
a “light” crowd had a positively breezy
10 square feet to themselves.
In any event, once he had the approximate
average number of students in each grid, he
could then easily calculate the number of
grids in an area occupied at a given density,
and quite quickly come up with a very good
estimate of how many people were in a given
crowd.
Thus, the now Gold Standard, and remarkably
simple, “Jacobs’ Method” was born.
This may sound like an overly simple solution
but the truth is, it’s strikingly accurate
when done by non-biased observers, and modern
technology has only made it easier.
For instance, tools like Google Earth have
made learning the exact size and area of a
location, as well as dividing an area into
grids, an almost trivial feat for just about
anyone.
And thanks to ubiquitous media coverage, any
large gathering of people is going to have
video or photographic footage (if not just
scanning the Tweetosphere for people in the
crowd who may have gotten a good shot and
posted it online).
So breaking things down from there is relatively
trivial.
Of course, one could get really fancy and
take a photo of an entire crowd and use a
bit of custom designed image processing software
to programmatically count the people in a
crowd for a more exact number, but the extra
level of accuracy here over the properly executed
Jacobs’ Method isn’t really typically
that much, nor all that necessary.
Of course, when giving estimations, sometimes
the news media or the organisers of an event
do like to fudge the numbers a bit.
Perhaps the most famous example is that of
the Million Man March- a mass gathering of
African Americans (mostly men) that took place
in 1995.
As you can probably guess from the name of
the march, event organisers afterwards were
very insistent that at least a million men
had attended, with estimates going as high
as two million.
However, the National Parks Service disagreed
and offered up a much lower, but still extremely
significant figure of around 400,000 individuals.
But when something is called the Million Man
March, 400,000 seems a bit of a letdown, even
though it’s logically very much not; getting
400,000 people (about 1.2% of all African
Americans in the United States at the time)
to show up at such an event in Washington
DC is really quite a feat.
Nevertheless, the NPS’s estimate incensed
a key player behind the march, Louis Farrakhan,
so much so that he threatened to sue the NPS.
As a direct result of the brouhaha that followed,
the NPS is now banned by congress from estimating
the size of crowds in Washington, at least
publicly.
As they noted, if the President asks them
for how big a crowd was, they’re happy to
crunch the numbers given footage of the crowd.
They just aren’t technically supposed to
use tax payer dollars in this way anymore,
so wouldn’t share that information with
the media who, of course, could quite easily
come up with their own estimates.
So how many people actually attended the Million
Man March?
While an exact figure is impossible to discern,
most researchers are in agreement that the
original estimation of the NPS is pretty accurate.
For example, in 2004 a pair of researchers,
Clark McPhail and John D. McCarthy, worked
out that in the location of the gathering
there would have been space for a maximum
of 1,048,206 people assuming that every inch
of the crowd was as densely packed as safely
possible at 2.5 square feet per person.
In the end, from the pictures available of
the gathering, they determined that the NPS’s
estimate of about 400,000 was quite accurate.
This isn’t a one-off case either; research
has shown that the estimates of event organizers
are consistently higher than those of the
police, who tend to give more accurate predictions
given the events generally take place in gathering
spaces that are well documented in case of
emergency, in terms of how many people they
can safely hold.
Of course, event organizers (and sometimes
the media) can have something to gain by overstating
how large a crowd is, while the police and
other official agencies generally do not.
That said, there are certainly examples out
there of official agencies intentionally adjusting
announced crowd sizes for one reason or another
just like organisers love to do.
Luckily, there’s a simple method of accurately
estimating the size of a crowd that’s free
from bias, and these days can be easily done
even just by some guy sitting at home in his
PJs surfing the web half way across the world
from where the event is actually happening,
which is more than a little amazing.
Don’t you think?